think you know tuck turns well think
again after all we all know that tuck
turns look like
this but did you know they also look
like this and this and
this as it turns out pun intended tuck
turns are way more diverse than we
thought they were and in this video I'm
going to count down five skill levels of
those tuck turns to keep you challenged
regardless of where you're at in your
flow Journey
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to give a little
love to what I think is an
underappreciated corner of the PO world
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro tery Toys spinballs and
Ultra Bo for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- bus friend of the
channel Becca beinen thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission so I think nearly
everybody encounters some form of Tuck
turns fairly early on in their po
Journey tuck turns involve taking
localized reels around your hips and
shoulders and moving back and forth
between them essentially transforming
those reels into flowers that wrap all
around your body and certain people have
made the case that they're basically the
first type of body Tracer that most pois
Spinners encounter it's it's me I'm
people and given that I think the tuck
turns are criminally underappreciated
I'm going to make my case by showing you
five different versions of Tuck turns
that are going to challenge people at a
variety of different skill levels so
let's dive in trick number one beginner
shoulder reels so I'm going to keep
things as simple as I possibly can for
this first trick on the list I'm not
even going to bother with all the stuff
that goes under your armpits or anything
like that I'm just going to give you
what you can do when you tuck those po
over your shoulders as you turn from
side to side the how-to on this is
pretty easy all you got to do is start
by facing over to one side of the stage
with the pois spinning reverse drop them
both back behind your shoulders then
turn your upper body over to the other
side of the stage and bring them back
out you can use pendulums to switch the
direction of them and start spinning
them reverse once again drop them behind
your your shoulders and turn to the
other side of the stage and once again
pull them back out when you get this up
to speed you can just go simply back and
forth back and forth putting little
Loops behind your shoulders instead of
the Stalls and using those pendulums to
bring you to a stop on either side and
the benefits of this are not just that
you're only engaging the parts of Tuck
turns that are easiest to learn when
gravity is helping you out but also you
wind up with a pattern coming out of it
that I think looks pretty cool in its
own right and honestly you can just use
this pattern to get around the stage too
use it with some lunges or some side
steps to go from side to side or you can
use it with some tandus to really point
out every single time you reach the edge
of one side of this pattern and I do
regret to inform you that that's the
only trick on the list that you do not
need to know how to do those pesky hip
reels for so let's dive into our next
pick trick number two beginner
intermediate split opposites tuck turns
so no BS I was actually first introduced
to this version of the trick in a video
from more than a decade and a half ago
of Woman spinning fire and trying to
figure out what was going on with those
Loops over and under her shoulders at
the time I really didn't have a good
vocabulary for talking about what tuck
turns were or even a name for them
necessarily and I spent an entire day
working out what exactly was going on
there it wasn't until years later that I
realized that this fit into the tuck
turns family I also got to say I think
split time opposites tuck turns are
right up there with together same tuck
turns in terms of their aesthetically
pleasing value when you're working with
together opposite tuck turns you up with
this weird kind of flapping motion that
can be a little uncomfortable for your
shoulders and well in Split Time same
direction you wind up having to add an
extra half a beat on either side in
order to switch which hand is leading
unless you're just going to turn your
way through it but with these split time
opposites tuck turns you get something
that's got a nice Dancy quality to it as
well as something that's fairly easy to
pull off you're doing your above
shoulder and below shoulder reels at
exactly the same time and just carrying
them from side to side and arguably you
could say that this doesn't look exactly
like what we would expect from a tuck
turn and that leads us deeper into the
list and for the first time to explore
what happens when we tweak the hand path
trick number three intermediate linear
tuck turns okay so hold the phone linear
tuck turns who says such things well I
do for one and part of that comes out of
my recognizing that tuck turns are a
form of body tracing so all of the rules
that apply to body tracing elsewhere
also apply here so let me take you
through the idea here if we think of
tucks as essentially being flowers that
were wrapping around our body then we
have the option of collapsing those
flowers down to just a linear isolation
so now I can take my tuck turns back and
forth across a horizontal line or I can
take them up and down a vertical line
technically I could also do this on
diagonals if I wanted to but you get the
gist essentially there's a way of
presenting these that make the fact that
their body tracers super obvious and
this means that we have more options for
how we present present them too now our
tuck turns can work in both direct as
well as indirect movement as well as the
fact that we can take those movements
from side to side of the stage and
really make them punch in ways that we
can't with that original flower version
body tracers of course are always
exciting because they involve wrapping
the PO around the body hence the name
and in the process of doing these in a
linear fashion we're also making them
work in such a way that these really
really tight turns now have a completely
different presentation to them and the
more presentations we have the more
options we have for how we can perform
them and hey if you're one of those
eagle-eyed people that is looking at
those linear tuck turns and thinking my
goodness those look so much like pois
snakes well guess what not only are you
totally right but you've guessed where
we're going for the next two tricks on
this list trick number four intermediate
Advanced vertical snakes Okay so in
terms of the actual physical skills of
Performing these yeah they may not
necessarily qualify intermediate to
advanced level but working inside of
this framework and thinking of them as
being tuck turns is something that is
going to Noodle your Noggin just a
little bit see if we conceptualize our
tuck turns as merely being snakes that
have been expanded out into full flowers
then the reverse is also true and we can
think of every snake move that we have
access to as being a type of Tuck turn
as well in particular I'm a big fan of
these vertical snakes that go up the
sides of the body whether they happen to
end in extensions or in turns that keeps
the tuck turn going the entire way
around it also helps that this is a
version of a together opposites tuck
turn that actually looks presentable
even if it isn't necessarily working
within the letter of the law of what
that might look like as a direct
translation in the same way that it
would and together same see I would
think that the presentation that we
would expect by default with together
opposites tuck turns is to tuck both of
the hands behind the body at the exact
same time which results in those weird
shoulder articulations that I was
talking about before but if we instead
instead make the choice that we're going
to Alternate which hand is going to tuck
behind us all of a sudden we go into
those snake territories and we get a
much cooler looking trick out of it and
hey real quickly before we jump on to
the last poy trick on this list did you
know that 63% of you out there watching
right now are probably not subscribed to
this channel that's a silly choice I
make tons of Awesome videos about poy
tricks tutorials video essays flow and
inspiration so if you're one of those 63
I would really really urge you to
consider subscribing to this channel to
help it grow and you know what that also
helps people find the channel as well
all right and now for my final pick on
this list ooh it is the ghost of tech
poy past trick number five Advanced the
aliens Diamond so this one's definitely
going to take some explanation a long
long time ago right before the first
kinetic fire actually I played host to
Charlie Cushing and alien John here in
Washington DC and we spent an entire
week hanging out and trading ideas for
Tech pooy One of which was this bizarre
creation see alien John was teaching
some workshops on body tracers and one
of the things that he was teaching was
applications of snakes at one point I
don't remember who but one of us offered
up the suggestion of what if there was a
way to perform xan's diamond with snakes
and we all got really confused over it
because we realized that the traditional
way that xan's diamond is done would
always require you to put your hands
through your shoulders in order to
perform it and then alien John had a
flash of inspiration
he realized that even though the
traditional algorithm for putting
together the diamond wouldn't work there
is a different algorithm that would the
key here is that you're switching back
and forth on the top and bottom which
side you're going to after you perform
that vertical in the process this also
means that you have to turn once but the
result winds up being a body traced
xan's diamond oh my goodness we were so
excited by this and once again I am
saying that tuck turns fit into the
general vicinity of snakes so I'm going
to say that if you want to try the most
advanced tuck turn I can think of this
is it hey real quickly before you head
out if you are interested in learning
more awesome stuff about tuck turns
guess what I have good news for you tuck
turns are the theme for the flow Circle
this month the flow circle is a weekly
exclusive lesson that's available only
to my patreon supporters and this month
the theme is tuck turns we'll be going
through a variety of exercises that will
help you master tuck turns in every
timeing in Direction mode as well as
various different presentations for them
check it out cuz there's going to be
some gems here the first lesson is
available now up at
patreon.com Factor pooy so what are your
favorite tuck turns I didn't just want
to say learn your tuck turns in all four
timing and Direction modes because I
think that would have been boring but
there's also likely a bunch that I
missed so let me know what they were
down in the comments
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you one and all
for helping to support my mission and
these videos and if you out there
watching are not currently subscribers
but you'd like to help me out you can do
that by heading on over to patreon at
rewards and even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you and if you're in the mood for
finding out more about really hard
versions of What otherwise would be
thought of as beginner poy tricks I've
got a pick for you uh check out my video
on five levels of the three beat weave
I'll go ahead and link to it down in the
description as well as up on screen
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow today and I'll see
you with a new video real soon take care
now peace oh